Just like what we have seen in the previous sessions,
we play with these five digits. And here's our question.
Take a moment and read it well!
Using these five digits,
how many three-digit numbers greater than 200 can be formed?
Let's read it again.
Three-digit numbers greater than 200.
And again we have two cases. When repetition is not allowed
and when it's allowed.
Let's understand the first case! We have to form three-digit numbers,
so we make three slots for each of the digits.
Read the question again.
Do we have a condition here?
Yes, the condition is that the three-digit number
must be greater than 200.
And we have seen before that if we have a condition,
we always start with it.
It means, we start with the hundredths place.
This is a golden rule. If you're given a condition always start with it.
Now ask yourself one simple question.
If the number has to be greater than 200,
then in how many ways can the hundreds place be filled?
Don't forget! We can use only one of these five digits.
Think, it's easy!
If the number has to be greater than 200,
then the hundredths place should have a digit greater than two.
So we can fill the hundredths place with a three or a four or a five.
In three ways correct?
This is a very common mistake that students do.
It's incorrect!
The hundredths place can be filled with a
two or a three or a four or a five.
Even 213 is greater than 200.
245 is also greater than 200.
T he only number that will not be greater than 200,
when 2 is in the hundredths place, is 200.
But here, zero is not one of the five digits.
So we don't have to worry about that special case of 200.
There are four ways in which the hundredths place can be filled.
With a 2 or a 3, or a 4 or a 5.
Not a one as the number has to be greater than 200.
Now we move on to the next slot.
Assuming we have filled the hundredths place with one of these four digits.
In how many ways can the tenths place be filled?
Think carefully.
One digit is used here.
In how many ways can we fill the second slot?
As one digit is gone four remain.
Simple! The second slot can be filled in four ways.
If we use a four here,
then one among one, two, three, and five can be used here.
If we use a two here,
then one among one, three, four, and five can be used here.
So having used one digit in the hundredths place,
the tenths place can be filled in four ways.
Now having used up two digits for the hundredths and the tenths place,
in how many ways can the unit's digit be filled?
As two digits are used,
obviously three would be left.
It can be filled in three ways.
We are filling the first and the second and the third slot.
So we multiply these numbers.
The total number of ways would be four times four times three.
It equals forty eight ways.
And what is this 48?
It is the number of
different three-digit numbers greater than 200,
that can be formed using these five digits.
But when repetition is not allowed.
Will the answer change if repetition is allowed?
Let's move to a new page.
We try to answer the second part here.
Using these five digits,
how many three-digit numbers greater than 200
can be formed, if repetition is allowed?
We make three slots to represent the three digits.
In how many ways can we fill the hundredths place?
As the number has to be greater than 200,
we can fill it with a two or a three or a four or a five.
Four ways.
Okay good! Now answer this question
Having used up one digit here,
in how many ways can we fill the second slot?
So after having used up one digit here,
does it mean that there are just four ways in which you can fill up the slot?
No, it does not.
Repetition is allowed if we use a three here.
We can use it again in the tenths place.
The number of ways in which the tenths and the unit's place can be filled
is independent of the condition as repetition is allowed.
The second slot or the tenths place can be filled with
any one of the five digits we have.
It can be filled in five ways.
And with the same logic, even the unit's place can be filled in five ways.
Why four ways for the first slot?
Because we cannot fill it with a one.
The number has to be greater than 200.
We multiply these numbers as we are filling the first,
and the second and the third slot.
Four times five is twenty and twenty times five is 100.
One hundred ways is the answer!
We can form one hundred three-digit numbers greater than 200,
using these five digits when repetition is allowed.
Do we have to start with the condition when repetition is allowed?
Nope! When repetition is allowed we can start off with any of the slots.
We will get the same answer.